hello there you're watching the press
preview our first look at what's on the
front pages as they arrive
over the next half an hour we'll see
what's making the headlines with
politics editor at galdem moya lothian
maclean
and economics correspondent at the
spectator kate andrews so a very good
evening to both of you nice to see you
both
so let's take a look then at what's
making the front pages first and
unsurprisingly last night's vigil but
turned violent is still dominating the
papers
the daily mail leading with shaming of
the met
safer streets for women pm acts as
police chief faces
inquiry is the headline in the eye
the daily telegraph leads with met
commissioner cressida dick
defending the police's handling of the
vigil
and that story is also in the metro
which leads with
met chief i'm going nowhere the
yorkshire post says a new transport hub
is to be set up in yorkshire creating
hundreds of new jobs in the region
and the financial times reports that the
u.s digital payments company stripe has
become
silicon valley's most valuable private
enterprise
so let's talk through some of those
headlines now with moya lothian maclean
and kate andrews so a proper welcome to
both of you
um one story in town really and that's
the aftermath
of the uh handling by police of
yesterday's vigil
in memory of sarah everard um different
takes in the papers but
we're kicking off with the metro aren't
we moya met chief i'm going nowhere
is the headline there alongside a
picture of one of the arrests last night
first of all though i'm interested to
get your take on it because i understand
that you were there
on clapham common last night and also
went to some of the protests
uh today as well so so what was your
impression of what was going on
well i think to start with it was
fascinating to see the difference
between
yesterday's protest and today's
gathering
because yesterday as we know uh it
resulted in
heavy-handed arrest over policing
several women were slammed to the floor
today the police presence was there
but there was no sort of enforcement of
violence they made no moves in the crowd
and the crowd dispersed peacefully
which i think says so much so it was
really interesting to
immediately compare and contrast that
response and the difference
the police action made upon the response
of the crowd well yes and um case if we
look at that headline it says
met chief i'm going nowhere cressida
dick today
saying that she was going to carry on
her intention was to carry on leading
the organization
she talked about the police handling
being fiendishly
difficult do you think that those calls
for her resignation which have come from
a number of quarters
should be heard
uh well there's going to be an inquiry
quite rightly so and we can come on to
that in some of the other headlines but
there's no doubting that this met
commissioner is overseeing
a real fracture and a very important
principle in the uk which is policing by
consent and
this has different layers the police
last night could have shown discretion
and instead as one said they went in in
the most heavy-handed
way and interpreted the coveted rules in
the harshest way
possible and other layers that we
continue to perpetuate this idea
that all gatherings are created
dangerously equal
during covet and that just isn't true
you even had the scientific advisor
sir patrick valens the chief scientific
advisor
saying very recently that there just
isn't a lot of evidence that this virus
can spread outside very easily at all
and
last year when we saw mass protests you
didn't see that
spike in the virus so the idea that this
was really a dangerous public health
situation is
very very debatable and that the met
police are going to use
the lockdown rules as cover for the
aggression that we saw last night
calls him to question this cove
legislation and it's not just a problem
for the met police it's a
problem for politicians as well because
mps are set to renew the coronavirus act
uh before the easter break um so it's
going to be interesting to see whether
or not these fractures really cause some
kind of break whether it be
in in public trust with the way they're
being police during this time
whether that be with the legislation
around coronavirus in a whole host of
areas
um you're looking at a very tense time
over the next few weeks do you agree
with that moyer because cressida dick
did talk about the fact that um the
current covert regulations meant that
it was unlawful to hold a gathering like
this a threat to public health that
officers had to take action
if people were putting themselves and
others at risk what do you make of our
argument
uh i think there's always a human right
to protest that's protected under the
human rights act
i would also say that when you meet a
peaceful protest as
kate said you need to meet with
discretion if they'd met it with
discretion
none of what happened yesterday would
have occurred when i was there
there was social distancing people were
wearing masks it was only as the police
moved in and forced people close
together that social distancing element
was lost
so i think i think cressida dick is
arguing her way out of the situation
based on the very vague coronavirus
regulations um but which ignore
the right we have to protest and cater
we move on to the yorkshire post
and their second story really they're
under a picture
from the vigil on clapham common it says
minister orders review into policing
of the event and just in the last few
minutes there's been
some quotations from boris johnson from
the prime minister that also reiterate
that
as well um will an inquiry make a
difference do you think
well there seems to be a bipartisan
agreement that something's gone badly
wrong you have the home secretary pretty
patel
you have the london mayors the decon
conservative labor coming together to
say that they're not pleased with what
they saw last night
and also they don't think that they've
had adequate justification
uh from president dick from the met
police as to why things went so badly
wrong
and i think an inquiry is quite right
because we need to get to the bottom of
how depression wasn't put into place why
it was decided that some of the harshest
tactics would be
used why these police would be putting
their hands on these women and who were
not acting in any kind of dangerous or
or violent manner and one thing i would
say we have to be slightly cautious
though is there's going to be great
desire on the part of politicians to
pass the book
to the met police now i think the met
police have a lot that they have to
answer for here this is certainly not to
let
them off the hook but let's remember
that these covered regulations these
laws that they're going to try to use as
cover
have been instituted and implemented by
politicians
so everybody's feeling very very nervous
at the moment but of course the people
who are most
impacted by this are those who would
have shown up to the visual those who
would have shown up to protest today
to make their voices heard who are
absolutely distressed by what's happened
to
sarah everard um so you know the real
victims in this situation
um of course they're at the very top and
then um very sadly women
who who were manhandled last night so
you're going to see i think a bit of a
battle back and forth between
politicians and the met police
as to who should be held most
accountable well yes and moy we have had
the most extraordinary outpouring
haven't we of frustration
anger stories of women suffering
harassment and abuse and that anger has
built up but it's
it's not just against the police is it
there's a criminal justice bill as well
there is government policy and and i
know that and the government is talking
about looking again at the domestic
abuse bill
looking at reopening they've reopened
this consultation on on violence against
women
do you think that enough is being done
in response
i think fundamentally there needs to be
really thinking of how we handle
violence against women
in this country and how much of
the problem we put onto the criminal
justice system to tackle
because it's quite obvious that they're
not fit for purpose you know the police
and the cps
we have the lowest rape convictions
we've had in a decade but
reports of rape arising and so the
police as an institution
as we've seen respond with violence
to you know peaceful protest and there
was also that statistic from 2019 where
it was one in 18
attacks by officers sex assaults and
attacks were not reported
or acted upon so there's a deep failing
within the police as a whole and i think
also what we should focus on
is what kate was saying about passing
the buck by politicians because
it's all good and well having an inquiry
but at the same time on monday there's
going to be a second reading
of the police crime courts and sen the
crew police
the police crime sentencing and courts
bill in parliament which seeks to
make some of the legislation around
protest and this restrictions that we're
seeing now
permanent so you can you can halt this
inquiry but if you're going to pass a
bill that
essentially bans protest for the
long-term foreseeable
future we're going to see more violent
responses to protests like this
and i'm going to show viewers the eyes
front page which says safer streets for
women pm
acts as police chief faces inquiry and
they pick up
when bullet points on that point and
that muay was making kate about this
police bill
getting a reading again tomorrow do you
share her concerns about the rights of
protest in that bill
well a lot of people have been raised
concerns about how this bill would
essentially take much of what's been
legislated through the coronavirus act
which allows uh police allows the
government really to crack down on the
right to protest
and it would institute it for the
foreseeable future indefinitely
it would be much easier for the police
to break the protest
if this bill were to pass now it has a
lot of things in it that both the
conservative and labour party would like
to say that they're for
tougher sentencing or crimes committed
against women for example
um so the fact that labour parties now
come out and said they don't plan to
vote for this
um is a big indicator that what has
happened over the past 36 hours has had
a huge impact
on people's awareness of what happens
when you crack down on these democratic
rights on these human rights as moyo
says
that enable us to protest because if you
start making it much more difficult
i think muay is right you are going to
see um these situations and the tensions
within them
boil over and that's not something
anyone wants to see
okay we're going to take a break at this
point uh lots more coming up
very shortly including could vaccine
passports
allow us all to have a summer holiday
we're going to talk about that shortly
welcome back you're watching the press
preview with me tonight politics editor
at
moya lothian maclean and economics
correspondent at the spectator
kate andrews so welcome back to you too
kate we're
looking at a story on the front page of
the daily telegraph next and the
headline is lockdown delay was lethal
mistake
pm's allies admit and we're talking a
year ago aren't we
we are talking a year ago but we're also
looking at the future because we know
inevitably there's going to be an
inquiry into how the
crisis was handled and already you can
see people positioning their arguments
to stand up in that inquiry and the
front page of the telegraph is um
citing close allies it says of the prime
minister um who are suggesting that the
prime minister accepts that he was
too late to implement the first lockdown
back in march 2020. now this is
something we
i i would argue we already knew based on
the government's current behavior you
can usually tell what they regret from
the past
for example we have such a tight
quarantine system now for international
travel because they regret having not
closed the borders earlier and we're now
in the longest lockdown hopefully we're
going to have certainly longer than the
first lockdown despite having vaccines
and i think a lot of that comes down to
the fact the prime minister regrets that
he didn't lock down
sooner in the first place um but again
his allies are giving him a
bit of the defense suggesting that he
was let down by scientific advisors
again we were passing the buck around
policing in the first half now we're
talking about it in the second half of
the sky newspapers
around the cove inquiry okay and i'm
going to move us on if that's all right
moya because there's another story in
the metro
that you were keen to talk about as well
and this is ba planning its own virus
passport
for passengers airlines obviously
desperate to get their numbers boosted
after a terrible year so
um what are british airways planning
according to this article
uh they're planning to issue vaccine
passports for
passengers who make bookings
international bookings with them
um basically based on the optimism that
international travel
will be back by summer or however it's
been predicted that because of the poor
vaccine response across europe that's
coming taking place
international travel probably won't be
in place so
this this very much seems like a bit of
like optimism on the part of ba as
opposed to pragmatism
and it's interesting isn't it kate
because could we see more and more
companies
deciding to go their own way and demand
proof
of vaccination or negative covid tests
before they allow people to use their
services and do you think that's a good
thing
i think international travel is a really
specific area first of all the airlines
feel like they've been badly
overlooked during the coba crisis
they're keen to get travel
up and started as soon as possible but
also i'm sure many of these airlines are
worried that they're going to be
considered liable
potentially if somebody who tested
positive was on one of their flights
it will be interesting to see how
quickly governments move because
it seems to be the case that we are
moving towards an internal vaccine
passport
um whether or not individual companies
deliver delivered to our governments
remains to be seen
but um it is expected and in some of the
consultations they're carrying out in
the next few months that will get an
answer on this